- [Instructor] Liz's math test
included a survey question
asking, how many hours
students that spent studying
for the test.
The scatter plot and trend line below
show the relationship
between how many hours
students spent studying
and their score on the test.
The line fitted to the model,
the line fitted to model the data
has a slope of 15.
So, the
line they're talking about is right here.
So this is the scatter
plot, this shows that
some student who spent
some time in between
half an hour and an hour studying
got a little bit less
than a 45 on the test.
This student here, who got a
little bit higher than a 60
spent a little under two hours studying.
This student over here,
who looks like they got
like a 94, or a 95
spent over four hours studying.
And so then they fit a line to it
and this line has a slope of 15.
And before I even read these choices
what's the best
interpretation of this slope?
Well, if you think this line
is indicative of the trend,
and it does look like that
from this scatter plot,
that implies that, roughly
every extra hour that you study
is going to improve your score by 15.
You could say, on average,
according to this regression.
So, if we start over here
and we were to increase by one hour
our score should improve by 15.
And it does, indeed, look like that.
We're going from, we're going in the
horizontal direction,
we're going one hour.
And then in the vertical
direction we're going
from 45 to 60.
So that's how I would interpret it.
Every hour,
based on this regression,
you could, it's not unreasonable to expect
15 points improvement.
Or at least that's what we're seeing
that's what we're seeing from
the regression of the data.
So let's look at which of these choices
actually describe something like that.
The model predicts that
the student who scored zero
studied for an average of 15 hours.
No, it definitely doesn't say that.
The model predicts that
students who didn't study at all
will have an average score of 15 points.
No we, we didn't see that.
Students, if you take this,
if you believe this model
someone who doesn't study at all
would get close to
would get between 35 and 40 points.
So like a 37, or a 38.
So, don't like that choice.
The model predicts the score will increase
15 points for each additional
hour of study time.
Yes, that is exactly what
we were thinking about
when we were looking at the model.
That's what a slope of 15 tells you.
You increase studying time by an hour
it increases the score by 15 points.
The model predicts that the study time
will increase 15 hours
for each additional point scored.
Well, no.
And first of all,
the hours is the thing that we use
the independent variable
and the points being
the dependent variable,
and this is phrasing it the other way.
And you definitely wouldn't
expect to do an extra
15 hours for each point.